etkileşimler konusuna devam ediyoruz
nelerden bahsetmiştik şu ana kadar güçlü
etkileşimlerden bahsetmiştik ne demiştik
metalik bağ İyonik bağ kovalent bağ
sonra bunların adlandırması polarlık
apolarlık bunların detaylarından
bahsettik polarlık apolarlık nerede
kullanılıyor işte şimdi anlatacağım
moleküller arası etkileşimlerde yani
zayıf etkileşimlerde kullanılıyor o
zaman vakit kaybetmiyoruz hazırsan
başlayalım moleküller arası
etkileşimlerle ilgili önce şu ifadeye
Bir bakalım istersen diyor ki
elektrostatik kuvvetler yardımıyla bak
zıt yüklü taneciklerin birbirini çekmesi
ya da aynı yüklü taneciklerin
birbirlerini itmesi sonucunda meydana
gelen etkileşimlere Biz moleküller arası
etkileşim diyoruz ve moleküller arası
etkileşimle ilgili şöyle önemli bir
ifade vardır Maddenin hal değişimlerinde
ve birbiri içerisinde dağılıp
dağılmaması da kesinlikle etkilidir
Mesela şöyle bir şey vardır Benzer
benzeri çözer diye bir ifade vardır
ileride göreceksin bunu bu şu demektir
polar madde ve iyonik madde polar
çözücülerde apolar maddeler ise apolar
çözücülerde iyi çözünür Çünkü bunların
molekül yapıları benziyor molekül
yapıları benzediği için birbirleriyle
olan etkileşimleri yani moleküller arası
etkileşim diğer ifadeyle zayıf
etkileşimleri söyleyemedim zayıf
etkileşimleri var o yüzden birbiri
içerisinde çözünmek İşte tam olarak bu
konuyla alakalı bu durum o zaman Bir
maddenin katı sıvı ya da gaz olması neye
bağlıymış bu moleküller arası
etkileşimlere bağlı mıymış bağlıymış ve
şöyle bir şey vardır moleküller arası
etkileşim ya da diğer ismiyle zayıf
etkileşim katı ve sıvı fazlarda kontrol
ettiğimiz bir durumdur gaz fazında
tanecikler arası etkileşimlerin çok çok
küçük olduğu için yok olduğunu
söyleyebiliriz olmadığını kabul
edebiliriz ama burada bahsettikleri hep
maddenin yoğun fazlarında yani katı ve
sıvı fazlarında olacak Dostum şimdi
burada kalıcı dipol geçici dipolü
söylemeden önce şunu bir hatırlayalım
polar molekül vardı polar molekül Neydi
bu işte Molekülün üzerinde bir kalıcı
kutu Allah düşüyordum asasın kalıcı
kutuplaşma vardı yani şöyle bir şeyden
bahsediyoruz kalıcı kutuplaşması şu yani
her zaman bir tarafı negatif bir tarafı
pozitif ama bazı moleküller de vardı ki
o kutuplaşma söz konusu değildi yani bir
tarafa eksi bir tarafa artı diyemiyordu
İşte o artı eksi kutuplaşması sabit
olduğu yapılar neydi polar moleküllerde
bunun olmadığı yapılara yani kutupsuz
olan yapılara ise apolar moleküller
diyoruz işte polar moleküllerde kalıcı
dipol bulunmaktadır yani polar molekül
eşittir kalıcı dipol apolar molekül
dediğimizde ise apolar molekül
dediğimizde ise bunda da geçici dipol
bulunmaktadır geçici dipol bunun diğer
ismi
indüklenmiş dipol şeklinde
söylenmektedir Burada da bunları
açıklıyorum Dostum bak İstersen şöyle
yaklaşarak bakalım Diyor ki bir kimyasal
türün iki farklı ucundan iki farklı tür
yük bulunması durumu Yani bir taraf
negatif bir taraf pozitif ne diyoruz
buna dipol diyoruz işte polar
moleküllerde mevcuttur dipol dediğimiz
şey kutuplu Yani iki farklı Kutup
anlamına gelmekte ve kimyasal türün
üzerinde Yani polar bir molek molekülde
değişmeyen bir artı eksi var ya Yani
sürekli bir taraf Eksi Bir taraf artı
İşte biz buna kalıcı dipol diyoruz ama
geçici dipol dediğimiz şeyde isse bir
kutuplaşma yok ama yanından bir şey
geçtiğinde veya moleküller birbirlerine
çarpışıp etkileştiğinde Kısmi bir
kutuplaşma meydana geliyor bir taraf
Eksi Bir taraf artı oluyor o sırada
diğer molekül bundan etkileniyor burada
Aslında o şeyler değişebiliyor yani
kutuplar sürekli değişebiliyor farklı
bir yönden etkilendiğinde farklı
kutuplaşma geçici dipol bu işte Yani
sürekli kalıcı bir polarla şma yok
geçici bir polarla şma var Bu da apolar
moleküllerin gerçekleştirdiği bir durum
ona da indüklenmiş dipol ya da ne
diyoruz işte geçici dipol diyoruz bunu
sana şöyle anlatayım dostum Bak en iyi
örneklerden bir tanesidir bunu 8 sınıfta
görmüştün Bu en son ünite vardı
elektriklenme konusu şöyle bir yapı var
mesela bak şu şekilde bir yapı var
yanına bir tane daha Yapı koyuyorum
Bunlar nötr yapılar bunları apolar
molekül gibi düşün bak apolar molekül
gibi düşün buraya şöyle bir tane Yapı
yaklaştırıyor eksi yük bir yapı
yaklaştırıyor ne olur eksi yüklü bir
şeyi yaklaştırdığımızda
nötrdür nötrdür ama bir şey
yaklaştırdığımızda
yandaki Molekül ne oluyor bundan
etkileniyor mu Bak bu da artı artı ı eki
eki eksi oldu peki bir şey söyleyeceğim
ben buradaki yapıyı yani yandan
getirdiğim yapıyı şuradan kaldırdım
kaldırdığım anda ne olur şu dağılır
değil mi şurası tekrar karışık hale
gelir ı ı ı eksi eksi eksi Yani tekrar o
kutuplaşma ortadan kalkar işte şöyle
eksi ı artı eki eki artı Hani bu hale
gelecek işte apolar molekülü böyle
düşünebilirsin bir kutuplaşma yok ama
bir şey yaklaştığında veya moleküller
birbirleriyle hafif etkileştiğinde
kutuplaşma meydana geliyor mesela
Soygazlar böyleydi soygazlarda herhangi
bir kutup yoktu ama diyelim buna bir şey
etki etti ve o sırada bu tarafa eksi bu
tarafa artı oldu o sırada yandaki helyum
hemen buna tepki veriyor bu hale geliyor
onun yanındaki tepki veriyor bu hale
geliyor onun yanındaki tepki veriyor bu
hale geliyor geçici bir polarla şma
oluyor İşte buna indüklenmiş dipol
diyoruz kalıcı dipe yani polar
moleküllerde olay çok basit zaten bir
taraf artı bir taraf eksi o değişmiyor
onun üzerindeki kutuplaşma hiçbir zaman
değişmiyor Ama apolarlığı bak burada da
örneklendirmek bilemesi örnek veriyorum
kısmen
ortadan kalkabilir Yani bunlar geçici
durumlar oksijen mesela apolar Bir
molekül diyelim artı eksi diye
kutuplaştırma etki ortadan kalkabilir mi
Tabii ki kalkabilir bunların arasında
Yani apolarların arasındaki etkileşim O
yüzden düşük oluyor geçici ya o yüzden
düşük bir etkileşim oluyor mesela
karbondioksit karbondioksit de aslında
bir kutuplaşma yoktu bunda karbondioksit
neydi şöyle bir yapıydı şu şekilde
diyeceksin ki hocam bu taraf kısmen eksi
bu taraf kısmen artı yani burada şöyle
bir durum var hani
merkeze bakarsan şunda
ortaklaşması baktığımızda şöyle bir
görüntü var Kutup söz konusu değil
kalıcı bir polarla şma söz konusu değil
ama mesela hcl ii dediğimizde hcl de
bariz bu taraf her zaman eksi bu taraf
her zaman artıdır ama Apolar bir
molekülde artı eksiyi çok fazla
anlayamazsın yanına bir şey geldiğinde
etkileştiğinde o oluyor işte yani apolar
moleküllerde geçici polarla şma meydana
geliyor şeyde ise polar moleküllerde ise
kalıcı polarla şma ya da kalıcı dipol
meydana geliyor diyoruz burada Mesela
bak işte hcl H2O Bunlar sabittir her
zaman moleküle baktığında Molekülün şu
tarafı hep böyle artıdır bu tarafı hep
eksideki kutuplaşma var ama şu molekül
sürekli dönebilmektedir dönebildiği için
bir şeyini kutbunu belirleyemez yani
apolar moleküllerde böyle bir durum söz
konusudur şimdi sana bak çok pratik bir
şey söyleyeceğim şöyle yazdım polar
molekül Ne yazayım iyonik bileşik ya da
iyon ya da iyonik bileşik de olur apolar
molekül ve soygaz Soygazlar ve apolar
moleküller apolar kabul ediliyordu Şimdi
şöyle bir durum söz konusu şunları aldım
Birazcık da şöyle alacağım biraz
küçültecek Bir saniye h küçültemiyorum
bak şimdi polar molekül se bunda dipol
vardır ya da kalıcı dipol aynı şey
demektir iyonik bileşiğin zayıf
etkileşimdeki karşılığı iyondur Sonuçta
iyonik bileşiğin yapısında iyon
bulunmaktadır apolar molekül ve
Soygazların zayıf etkileşim karşılığı
ise indüklenmiş dipolü indüklenmiş dipol
düdükl denmiş şey pardon indüklenmiş
dipol dediğimiz olay neydi işte geçici
dipolü yani kutuplaşma geçici oluyordu
değişken oluyordu şöyle bir şey vardır
daha sonra göreceğiz bunları dipol dipol
birazdan bahsedeceğim bunda dipol dipol
iyon dipol sonra indüklenmiş dipol
indüklenmiş dipol ki bunun özel ismi
London kuvvetleri bir şey daha var iyon
indüklenmiş dipol Bir de dipol
indüklenmiş dipol Bunlar bizim zayıf
etkileşimler imiz şöyle birazcık şu
arayı hop çok açtım Hah şöyle açtım niye
açtığımı söyleyeceğim bak şimdi dipol ne
demekti dipol polar molekülde oluyordu
değil mi o zaman dipol dipol kimle kimin
arasında oluyordur polar molekülle polar
molekül arasında oluyor iyon dipol diyor
iyon dipol kimlerin arasında olur dipol
dediğimiz polar moleküldür iyon
dediğimiz iyonik bileşikli ya da şöyle
iyon yazabiliriz iyonla polar molekül
arasında gerçekleşiyor diyebilirsin
indüklenmiş dipol indüklenmiş dipol
dediğimiz ya apolar apolar arasında olur
ya apolar soygaz arasında olur ya da
soygaz soygaz arasında olur Çünkü
indüklenmiş dipol dedim mi aklımıza Bu
ikisi geliyordu burada gördüğün gibi
iyon indüklenmiş dipol diyor o zaman ne
olacaktır iyonik bileşikle apolar
molekül arasında ya da soygaz arasında
görülmekte Bu ne diyor dipol indüklenmiş
dipol Bu da kimle kim arasında olur
polarla apolar molekül arasında
olacaktır dostum İşte şu tablo var ya
şurası Sana bütün zayıf etkileşimleri
öğretmekte yani polar molekülü apolar
molekülü biliyorsan iyonik bileşikleri
zaten daha önceden öğretmişti Metal
ametal bileşikleri bunları biliyorsan şu
tablodan dolayı hepsini çatır çatır
yapabilirsin dipol dipol polarla polar
iyon dipol iyonik la polar işte
indüklenmiş dipol indüklenmiş dipol ya
da London dedi apolar apolar gibi bunu
bu şekilde bariz bir şekilde
yapabiliyorsun şu tablo O yüzden çok
işine yarayacak bunu kenara not et
önemli bir ifade var Bak burada
moleküller üzerindeki kalıcı dipoller
oluşması ya da sadece geçici dipol
oluşabilmesi moleküller arası oluşan
etkileşimleri belirleyen faktördür İşte
şu tablodan bahsediyoruz bu kalıcı dipol
ya da geçici dipol olması ya da iyonik
olması ne yapıyor bu moleküller arası
etkileşimleri yani zayıf etkileşimleri
belirliyor şimdi gel bakalım örneklerde
ne diyor bana vermiş diyor ki Yukarıdaki
moleküllerden hangileri üzerinde kalıcı
dipoller vardır yani bana neyi soruyor
hangileri polar moleküldür diye soruyor
Aslında sorduğu soru tam olarak bunu
şeyde görmüştük kovalent bağlı
bileşiklerden sonra anlatmıştım onu
neydi polar moleküller apolar moleküller
sadece c ve
htane bu HC n ü farklı cins atom var
polar molekülü yapıştır geç demiştim nf3
diyor di azot 5A grubu Merkez atom 5A
grubu ama Grup numarası 5 olmasına
rağmen ne olmuş 3 bağ yapmış yani Grup
numarasından az bağ yaptığı için polar
molekül hangilerinde kalıcı dipol var
dediği için ne diyoruz polar moleküller
olan 2 ve 3 diyoruz cevabımız D seçeneği
şimdi demin söylediğim bir şey vardı ya
işte bu moleküller arası etkileşimlerin
tablosu işte burada Bak ne diyoruz vaner
wals etkileşimleri ve Hidrojen bağı
şeklinde ikiye arıyoruz vaner wals
etkileşimleri işte demin söylediğim
polar Molekülün karşılığı dipol neydi
iyonik bileşiğin karşılığı iyondur ya da
iyonun karşılığı iyondur apolar molekül
ya da soygazın karşılığı ise neydi
indüklenmiş dipolü işte burada Bak ne
diyor dipol dipol etkileşimi polar polar
arasındaki etkileşim iyon dipol
etkileşimi ve indüklenmiş dipol
etkileşimleri diyoruz işte indüklenmiş
dipoller de kendi içerisinde
ayırabiliriz Aslında iyon indüklenmiş
dipol ve dipol indüklenmiş dipol
şeklinde de söyleyebiliriz neydi iyon
iyon dipol dediği Nedir o zaman iyonik
bileşikle polar arasındaki etkileşim
indüklenmiş dipol indüklenmiş ya da
London etkileşimi dediğimizde ise apol
apolar arasında ya da işte soygaza polar
soygaz soygaz arasında iyon indüklenmiş
dipol derse iyonik bileşikle polar
arasında ya da iyonik bileşikle soygaz
arasındaki etkileşim dipol indüklenmiş
dipol dediğinde ise ne diyoruz polarla
apolar ya da polarla soygaz arasındaki
etkileşim diyoruz Dostum şimdi burada
bak dipol dipol le başlayalım istersen
dipol dipol diyor ki aynı ya da farklı
polar moleküllerin bir birbirine
yaklaşması sonucunda meydana gelen bir
etkileşimdir zıt kutuplar elektrostatik
çekim güçleriyle birbirine döner ve ne
olur işte burada çekim meydana gelir
örnek veriyorum hcl hcl'de Klor tarafı
eksiden tarafı artıdır şöyle oluyor bak
hcl molekülü geldi Şöyle duruyor Bu bu
taraf eksi bu taraf artı Ya diğer hcl
molekülü şöyle yaklaşıyor şu şekilde
yaklaşıyor Neden Çünkü burası artı
Burası eksi Şu arada etkileşim oluyor
diyelim şöyle üç boyutlu düşüneceğiz hcl
molekülü bu sefer böyle yaklaşacaktır
Neden Çünkü burası artı Burası eksi zıt
yükler böyle birbirini çekecek bir tane
daha yapalım şöyle Heh şöyle şu şekilde
çizdik bu taraf CL bu taraf H + eki işte
bunlar zıt yüklü şeylerin olduğu
yerlerin yapıların olduğu yerlerin
birbirlerine dönerek birbirlerini
etkilemesi sonucunda ne oluştu işte
polar moleküller arasında dipol dipol
etkileşimi oldu yani kalıcı dipol içeren
moleküllerin arasındaki etkileşime Biz
ne diyormuş dipol dipol etkileşimi
diyormuş örneklerde vardır ilk ha Bak
burada H C'yi göstermiş Görüyor musun
bak artı ile eksi etkileşmek ile artı
etkileşmek eksi ile artı artı ile eksi
artı ile eksi Bunlar birbirleriyle
etkileşmeler zıt kutuplarının birbirini
elektrostatik çekimlerle çekmesi
durumunda meydana gelmekte bir sürü
örnek yazabiliriz yani polar moleküller
olan hcl başka hbr de of2 h2s H2O C2 h5
Oh yani polar moleküllerin hepsinin
arasında ne vardır dipol dipol var
vardır ama bazılarının arasında
Ekstradan bir bağ Daha var onun
detaylarından bahsedeceğim burada
özellikle H2 oyu ve C2 h5 ohı yuvarlak
içine alıyorum evet bunlarda dipol dipol
var ama daha etkili bir bağ da var Onu
ilerleyen kısımlarda söyleyeceğim ve
hiçbir zaman unutmaman gereken bir şeyi
söylüyorum Şu tablo vardı ya bu
Tablodaki etkileşimler genel olarak
güçlü etkileşimlerden Zayıftır bu
genellemeye yapabiliriz ama genelleme
diyorum Tabii ki yani İyonik bağ şöyle
geldiğimizde İyonik bağ dip dipen
güçlüdür kovalent bağ dipol dipen
güçlüdür şöyle örneklendir bak hcl dedim
değil mi H C'yi yazdım sonra nokta nokta
nokta yaptım hcl Bir tane daha çizdim
şöyle bir şey yaptım Bak şuraya 1 dedim
şuraya 2 dedim ikinci Bağ nedir diye
sorarsa dipol dipolü neden iki polar
arasındaki etkileşim olduğu için Peki 1
nedir Farklı ametal atomları arasında
molekül içi bağ Bak bu atomlar arası bağ
bu polar kovalent bağdır bak kovalent
bağ şöyle yazdım ve polar kovalent bağ
dipol dipen oldukça güçlüdür Bunu sakın
unutma Yani molekül içi Bağlar atomlar
arası Bağlar bu moleküller arası
bağlardan yani zayıf etkileşimlerden
daha büyüktür bir diğeri iyon dipol
etkileşimi yani nedir anyon ya da
katyonun diğer bir ifadeyle işte iyonik
bileşikteki anyon ya da katyonun polar
bir molekülle etkileşimdir mesela sodyum
klorür suyun içine attım değil mi suyun
içerisine attığımda ne olacak ortama
sodyum + 1 ve Klor -1 iyonları verecek
mi verecek su da vardır Bak bizim
suyumuz var su şöyle bir yapı hidrojen
tarafları şuralar hidrojen tarafları bu
taraflar artıdır oksijen tarafı da
eksiden şurası oksijen Bunlar da
hidrojen şimdi bu H2O molekülü sodyumla
etkileşebilecek
o da hidrojen tarafıyla
bak H2O yu şöyle yazdım değil mi H2O
şöyle yazıldı şurada Klor iyonu var
şurada da sodyum iyonu var şöyle
gösterdim Şuradaki bak şu bağ iyon dipol
etkileşimi dipol etkileşimi Ama şu Bağ
nedir polar kovalent bağdır kovalent bağ
ne nen Çünkü bu atomlar arasında diğeri
moleküller arası aynı şekilde şu da
nedir yine iyon dipol etkileşimi diyoruz
dostum ve Bak burada da söylüyor işte
iyon dipol etkileşimleri molekül içi
kovalent bağlardan ve iyonik
bileşiklerdeki iyonik bağlardan daha
Zayıftır dedim ya bak moleküller arası
etkileşim ya da zayıf etkileşimler
İyonik bağdan kovalent bağdan daha
Zayıftır işte suya tuz attığında
gerçekleşen olay şudur su molekülleri
Bak şöyle Klor iyonunu sarıyor Ne
tarafıyla sarıyor artı tarafıyla sarıyor
görüyor musun böyle bir sarma şekli var
aynı şekilde sodyum iyonunu da suyun
eksi tarafı sarıyor bu şekilde ne
oluşuyor iyon dipol etkileşimleri
oluşuyor Bak örnekte ne diyor Aşağıdaki
maddelerden hangisi suya ilave
edildiğinde iyon dipol etkileşimi
meydana gelir su neydi su su su neydi
polar bir moleküldür değil mi polar
molekül yani dipol kısmı sudan geliyor o
zaman benim iyonik bir şey atmam lazım
buraya iyonik bir şey atayım ki ortamda
iyon oluşsun iyonik bir madde ya bu
kovalent kovalent Hatta polar kovalent E
bu da polar kovalent Hatta şey diyeyim
ya polar molekül diyeyim polar molekül E
bu da polar molekül e Bunlar hepsi
kovalent bağlı yapılar iyon vermiyor
ortama aynı şekilde bu apolar molekül ve
bu da yani kovalent yapılı Bu da iyon
vermiyor ama naoh suya ne verir na + ve
Oh eki verir iyon verdi E ne oldu o
zaman iyonla polar arasında etkileşim
meydana geldi o yüzden cevap ne
olacaktır burada e seçeneği olacaktır
ince bir şey söyleyeceğim İnce bir şey
hcl polar Bir molekül bunu suya atarsak
bak önemli bir şeyden bahsediyorum bunu
suya attığımızda polar polar ne olacak
Burada dipol dipen bahsedebilir miyiz
Yani çözüm Daha doğrusu iyonlaşmak kısmı
varsa bahsedebiliriz ama hcl suya ne
verir H ve clle verir değil mi yani
ortamda iyon var o yüzden asit ve bazlar
suya atıldığında burada ne oluşmakta
Ayrıca iyon dipol de oluşmakta ekstra
bir bilgi olarak bunu da vermiş olayım
bakalım örnekte ne diyor polar
moleküller arasında dipol dipol
etkileşimleri oluşur Evet polar
moleküller polar dipol Evet iki polar
molekül arasında ne oluyordu dipol dipol
oluyordu doğru iyon dipol etkileşimleri
bileşiği oluşturan kimyasal bağlardan
daha Zayıftır iyon dipol zayıf
etkileşimde e kimyasal bağlar bileşiği
oluşturan kimyasal bağlar ya kovalent
bağd ya da iyonik bağd Evet bunlardan
daha Zayıftır Doğrudur h2s sıvısının ki
polar bir molekülden bahsediyoruz
moleküller arasında dipol dipol
etkileşimleri var Evet doğru çünkü bu
bir polar molekül moleküller arasında
dipol dipol var doğru kn3 bu iyonik bir
madde suya K ve no3 verecektir ha diyor
ki tuzunun sulu çözeltisinde ise iyon
dipol etkileşimler oluşur Evet doğru
çünkü kn3 iyonik bir madde suyla
karışırsa ne olur iyon dipol olur doğru
bir ifadedir o zaman cevabım ne olacak E
seçeneği olacaktır buradaki örneğe
bakalım Diyor ki Yukarıdaki maddelerden
hangilerinin kendi molekülleri arasında
dipol dipol etkileşimleri meydana gelir
bak dipol dipol polar moleküller
arasında oluyordu değil mi he bakalım
şimdi karbon 4A grubu bu 1 S2 2 S2 2 P6
3 S2 3 P3 yani 5A grubu E bu da hemen
sonrası olduğuna göre 6a grubu Bu da bir
sonraki olduğuna göre 7A grubu E şimdi
Merkez atom burada p Klor ona bağlanıyor
e 5A grubu ama 3 bağ yapmış O zaman
polar bir molekülden bahsediyorum cs2
karbon disülfür daha önce söylemiştim
karbon burada 4 bağ yapıyor Neden Çünkü
6a grubu Burada 2 bağ yapacak şöyle bir
yapısı vardı Levis yapısını hatırlayalım
6a grubunun böyleydi 2 bağ yapabiliyor
şu anda iki tane tek noktası olduğu için
e karbon 4 bağ yapabiliyordu O yüzden
cs2 nin yapısı şöyle bir yapıydı e
Merkez atom Grup numarası kadar bağ
yaptığı için cs2 ne olacaktır apolar
olacaktır CL2 aynı metal atomlar
arasında oluştuğu için bu zaten apolarda
dipol dipol oluşturacak sadece polar
moleküllerde Bu da yalnız birdir cevabım
a seçeneğidir Evet dostum London
etkileşimleri var sırada Bir sonraki
derste London etkileşimlerinde
bahsedeceğim onlar ile ilgili
detaylardan bahsedeceğim Bence burayı
bir sindir dipol dipol etkileşimleri ve
iyon dipol etkileşimleri önemli bir
kısımdır tekrar hatırlatayım dipol dipol
olması için polar polar arasında
olmalıydı iyon dipol olması için iyonik
bir madde ile polar arasında olmalıydı
ifadelerini kullanmıştık ya da işte
ortamda iyon varsa hcl nh3 mesela Bunlar
da ortama iyon verebilmekte asit ve
bazlar da suya iyon verebilmekte haliyle
ortamda iyon varsa iyonla polar
arasındaki etkileşime de biz ne diyoruz
iyon dipol etkileşimi diyoruz dostum
bunları hatırlatmış olayım bir sonraki
dste London kuvvetlerinden devam
edeceğim beni dinlediğin için teşekkür
ederim kanala abone olursan çok mutlu
olurum Bir sonraki D görüşmek üzere
hoşça kal